Cuando un movimiento incluye en su discurso
un lenguaje de igualdad de género,
aumenta drásticamente la posibilidad de que adopte la no violencia,
y por lo tanto, la probabilidad de éxito.
La investigación encaja con mi propia documentación
de la organización política en Israel y Palestina.
He visto que los movimientos que acogen a las mujeres en posiciones de liderazgo,
como el que he documentado en un pueblo llamado Budrus,
eran mucho más propensos a alcanzar sus objetivos.
Este pueblo estaba bajo una amenaza real de ser borrado del mapa
cuando Israel inició la construcción del muro de separación.
La ruta propuesta requería
la destrucción de los olivos de esta comunidad, sus cementerios
y, en última instancia, cerrar el pueblo desde todos los lados.
Por un inspirado liderazgo local,
lanzaron una campaña de resistencia no violenta para evitar que eso sucediera.
Las probabilidades estaban masivamente en contra de ellos.
Pero tenían un arma secreta:
una niña de 15 años
que con valor saltó delante de una excavadora
que estaba a punto de arrancar un árbol de olivo, deteniéndola.
En ese momento, la comunidad de Budrus se dio cuenta de lo que era posible
si le daban bienvenida y confianza a las mujeres a participar en la vida pública.
Y así fue que las mujeres de Budrus fueron día a día a las líneas del frente,
usando su creatividad y visión para superar los obstáculos que enfrentaron
en una lucha sin armas de 10 meses.
Y como seguramente se puede decir en este punto,
ganaron al final.
La barrera de separación se cambió por completo
a la línea verde reconocida internacionalmente,
y las mujeres de Budrus llegaron a ser conocidas por toda Cisjordania
por su energía indomable.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Quiero parar un segundo, si me permiten,
porque quiero abordar dos malentendidos muy graves
que podrían darse en este punto.
El primero de ellos es que no creo que las mujeres
sean intrínseca o esencialmente más pacíficas que los hombres.
Pero sí creo que en el mundo actual,
las mujeres experimentan el poder de manera diferente.
Después de tener que navegar en la posición menos poderosa
en varios aspectos de su vida,
las mujeres suelen ser más hábiles
en la forma de presionar subrepticiamente para el cambio
contra actores grandes y potentes.
El término "manipuladora", muchas veces usado contra las mujeres despectivamente,
refleja una realidad en la que las mujeres a menudo han tenido que encontrar maneras
distintas a las de confrontación directa para lograr sus objetivos.
Y la búsqueda de alternativas a la confrontación directa
es el núcleo de la resistencia no violenta.
Ahora el segundo posible malentendido.
He hablado mucho de mis experiencias en Oriente Medio,
y algunos podrían estar pensando ahora
que nuestra solución es entonces educar a las sociedades musulmanas y árabes
para que incluyan más a sus mujeres.
Si tuviéramos que hacer eso, ellos tendrían más éxito.
Ellos no necesitan este tipo de ayuda.
Las mujeres han sido parte de los movimientos más influyentes
de Oriente Medio,
pero tienden a ser invisibles para la comunidad internacional.
Nuestras cámaras se centran principalmente en los hombres
que a menudo terminan involucrados en las escenas más polémicas
que encontramos tan irresistibles en las noticias.
Y terminamos con una narrativa que no solo borra a las mujeres
de las luchas en la región
sino que con frecuencia falsifica las propias luchas.
A finales de 1980, comenzó un levantamiento en Gaza,
y se extendió rápidamente a Cisjordania y Jerusalén Este.
Llegó a ser conocido como la Primera Intifada,
y quienes tienen alguna memoria visual de la misma
generalmente evocan algo como esto:
hombres palestinos que lanzan piedras a los tanques israelíes.
La cobertura del momento
hacía parecer como si piedras, cócteles molotov y neumáticos en llamas
fueron las únicas actividades que tenían lugar en la Intifada.
Sin embargo, también estuvo marcada por una organización no violenta generalizada
en forma de huelgas, sentadas y creación de instituciones paralelas.
Durante la primera Intifada,
sectores enteros de la población civil palestina se movilizaron,
a través de generaciones, facciones y clases.
Lo hicieron a través de redes de comités populares,
y su uso de la acción directa y proyectos de autoayuda comunales
desafiado la propia capacidad de Israel
de seguir gobernando Cisjordania y Gaza.
Según el propio ejército israelí,
el 97 % de los activistas durante la primera Intifada estaban desarmados.
Y aquí hay otra cosa que no es parte de nuestro relato sobre ese tiempo.
Durante los 18 meses de la Intifada,
las mujeres eran las que mandaban detrás de escena:
mujeres palestinas de todo tipo
estaban a cargo de la movilización de cientos de miles de personas
en un esfuerzo concertado para retirar el consentimiento de la ocupación.
Naela Ayyash, que se esforzó por crear una economía palestina autosuficiente
alentando a las mujeres en Gaza a cultivar hortalizas en sus jardines,
una actividad considerada ilegal por las autoridades israelíes en ese momento;
Rabeha Diab, que se hizo cargo de la autoridad de toma de decisiones
de todo el levantamiento
cuando los hombres que habían estado haciéndolo
fueron deportados;
Fatima Al Jaafari, que tragó volantes con las directivas del levantamiento
para difundirlos por todos los territorios
sin ser descubierta;
y Zahira Kamal,
que aseguró la perdurabilidad del levantamiento
liderando una organización
que pasó de 25 mujeres a 3000 en un solo año.
A pesar de sus logros extraordinarios,
ninguna de estas mujeres ha estado en nuestra narrativa de la Primera Intifada.
Hacemos esto en otras partes del mundo, también.
En los libros de historia, por ejemplo, y en nuestra conciencia colectiva,
los hombres son las caras visibles y los portavoces
de la década de lucha de 1960 por la justicia racial en EE. UU.
Pero las mujeres también eran una fuerza impulsora fundamental,
movilizando, organizando, tomando las calles.
¿Cuántos de nosotros pensamos en Septima Clark
cuando pensamos en la era de Derechos Civiles de EE. UU.?
Realmente pocos.
Pero ella jugó un papel crucial en todas las fases de la lucha,
sobre todo haciendo hincapié en la alfabetización y la educación.
Ella ha sido omitida, ignorada,
como tantas otras mujeres que desempeñaron un papel crítico
en el Movimiento de Derechos Civiles de EE. UU.
No se trata de obtener crédito.
Es más profundo que eso.
Las historias que contamos impactan profundamente nuestra forma de vernos,
y cómo creemos que se manejan los movimientos
y cómo se ganan los movimientos.
Las historias que hablan de movimientos como la Primera Intifada
o la era de Derechos Civiles de EE. UU.
impactan profundamente y tienen una influencia crítica
en la elección que los palestinos,
los estadounidenses
y la gente de todo el mundo hará
la próxima vez que encuentren una injusticia
y se armen de valor para enfrentarse a ella.
Si no elevamos a las mujeres que ejecutan un papel crítico en estas luchas,
no podremos ofrecer modelos para las generaciones futuras.
Sin modelos de conducta, se hace más difícil
que las mujeres ocupen el espacio que les corresponde
en la vida pública.
Y como hemos visto antes,
una de las variables más críticas
para determinar si un movimiento tendrá éxito o no
es la ideología de un movimiento con respecto al papel de las mujeres
en la vida pública.
Esta es una cuestión de si nos estamos moviendo
hacia sociedades más democráticas y pacíficas.
En un mundo donde ocurren tantos cambios,
y donde el cambio está obligado a continuar a un ritmo cada vez más rápido,
no es una cuestión de si vamos a hacer frente a los conflictos,
sino más bien una cuestión
de qué historias modelarán
la forma que elegiremos para librar conflictos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)